[Music]
jennifer aniston and lisa kudrow are
here for you making your friends reunion
dreams come true it turns out we know
each other so I know things
the former co-stars interviewed each
other four varieties actors on actor
series and took a stroll down memory
lane reminiscing about the first time
they met at the first table read for the
hits it comes you remember what everyone
was wearing but I do like a white linen
shirt and you had a bunch of like
seashells and necklaces on and you had
your hair pulled up in two little clips
and you had these little blonde tendrils
oh god bless hey I was trying to get
into the character I know you still
thought you were auditioning and you
actually already had the job
and while Jen and Lisa remember that
first meeting like it was yesterday they
had a surprisingly hard time remembering
pretty much anything else do you
remember any episodes we were in
together I don't know I don't know why
for some reason I kept thinking I was
thinking about the one with the the fire
alarm but I don't even think I was in
that one I don't know anything what
you're talking I'm talking about I mean
if you said the one with anything out
here I go yeah that episode the one with
the fire alarm made it uh let me refresh
your memory
season seven episode 12 the one where
they're up all night and Phoebe's fire
alarm wouldn't stop beeping okay so this
wire it's connected to this wire which
plugs into here okay so to get the
beeping to stuff all I have to do
[Applause]
well then peeps anyway that you revealed
that they have pretty cute nicknames for
each other they'll be like why am i
calling you that Lisa right and I can't
tell you jus as well even though it's
spelled J oo jo oh oh oh oh and remember
this famous scene from friends here we
go pivot
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah they referenced that too do you
mind if I pivot pivot pivot and get this
do you still watch friends episode I
love stumbling on a friends episode
Jennifer admitted to watching friends
bloopers on the internet with their
co-star Courtney Cox we stumbled on
bloop
there's bloopers online like 15 minutes
worth of bloopers that we sat there at
the computer like two nerds watching
these bloopers
laughing hours I've done it too um me
too me too
Lisa said that their time on the show
was so positive that she's had a
commitment issue with other series in
the years since I know that show worked
because we all committed to each other
to write you know it wasn't just
committing to a role committing like to
a contract I mean we all still love each
other
yeah our cast it's like that and that's
why that worked Jen and Lisa will get a
chance to reunite with the rest of the
friends cast Courtney Cox matt LeBlanc
Matthew Perry and David Schwimmer in an
HBO max special later this year ooh
that's interesting the show's co-creator
Marta Kauffman recently revealed in an
interview with The Wrap that they're
hoping to film the reunion in August
if coronavirus restrictions allow I
think it's gonna be really fun also when
we if we ever get out of quarantine get
to do our reunion show yes that will be
really great I can't wait to do that
Lisa and Jen dished on what fans can
expect we know it's not scripted that we
know yeah no no no no none of it I will
not be seedy and I will not be Rachel
although I kind of am
and when et spoke to Lisa last month she
couldn't help but gush about getting
back together with her old friends the
six of us haven't been in a room
together in front of people in 25 years
and only once a few years ago just
privately for dinner so and we had a
great time so I can only imagine it's
gonna be fun
I mean it'll be really fun
[Music]